okay raul yeah rubble
where are you from where'd you where
were we born chihuahua mexico and tell
me about your family you had both
parents growing up
no my my mother is in mexico and my
father
is citizen here in usa but he died
like let's say like five years ago i i
mean
him like three times you know like i
would raise people
with my mom only your dad wasn't really
in your life no
only three times in my life and how how
was your childhood
how well how was your childhood uh you
know i'm the
the men on the family you know i have to
grow up fast and
start help my mom with money by working
so i'm starting like selling i'm like
paper boi you know like
14 years i started working that's great
so i can help my mom with uh
money you know for the school and my
sister so we could have some money
and uh and you you went to school
in mexico yeah how did you lean learn
english
here when you came here what age like
i come here like when i'm 24 years old
to start working
how do you know i'm 42
and i'm learning like with a tv with a
closed caption and with my friends
so i want to work here so i i say i need
to learn english
and you know like i'm starting like i
never feel afraid to speak it so
i said yeah if somebody laughing you
know i will learn that's the key
yeah and my friend started me he showed
me like hey don't say this word
yeah just you have to say it this way
and that's it
that's how you are yeah and uh at 24 you
uh you did what when you came here you
were working
yeah i come in first like i have a
competition with my i used to work with
motorola
so they have the competition here in usa
and i like you know like
and when i have a chance they they they
they closed uh you know that fabric and
they pay me my money so i just come back
here to say oh i'm going to try to find
some job here and
stay here and yeah i stay here like work
in construction
like trying to find anything you know
yeah
and you like it here yeah i like it yeah
how does it compare your life in mexico
oh here is better like when i start
working here i can hold my
i have another brothers so i help them
like get
his story one is engineer another is
like
nursing so i have my yeah i held my
brothers to pay his school over there
they're in mexico yeah and are you a
legal
citizen no yeah no i never can get
nothing because my dad never put that
paper
he never helped me to get my status here
legal
and so today you're living where you're
on schedule
no i just i have a hotel room
yeah like the key program i'm staying
there okay
and are drugs a part of your life ah
not really you know like sometimes yeah
because it's like
like i need to get off too much problem
you know
my i ever like all these problems like
sometimes i
stress too much like depress me like
yeah take me down to just drugs you know
like trying to forget a little bit
like all the problems i have i open one
my company you know my painting business
company like four times
and every time it's going down
everything like i lose everything
why is that because i always have to
trust somebody you know
and put all the money in the bank
account you know for irs for paying
insurance
like work is completability and they can
take the money you know and i don't have
access because i don't have a social
security number yeah you're just you
know you're just winging it
yeah i i only have like that debit card
you know i can take three hundred bucks
and that's it
but i keep psychic check nothing you
know they always have the
100 control on all that money
so every time is like somebody's like
using the money you know they
they still see that money because i me i
can make like 30
000 you know one project like 20 24
like 12 like 8 000 like 10 000
they pay me big contracts you know they
pay you cash no check
and you don't pay did you pay taxes yeah
you do yeah i have
yeah that's why i have to have the
company like legal company with all the
insurance
and pay taxes you know and being an
illegal alien does that
is that how does that work i have to use
somebody
like he have to put a company and like i
can i have to trust all the money him he
he need to make others
yeah and that is always burning because
the people they don't want to do it
right
so they get they say oh i'm going to
take cash you know and start using cash
cash cash
they block me you know i have to woof
they let me with nothing i say well
there's nothing i can do what's the
solution i use close a i say
i have enough i don't want no problem
and i'm thinking you know like try to
find a way but
it's hard for me because i don't have
the social
security number you know so i can put a
company only my name
right i travel like i go to florida
to different states to paint
yeah because i get a contract you know
like i work
with really really good companies so
it's great it's great that you're
working and willing to work and
able to get good work but uh yeah
probably yeah you have a problem
how how we can trust people you know
like i always struggle but i always
get lost because of the money and do you
have uh
children or wife or girlfriend
no i when i have a girlfriend it's the
same problem so
i said no no no no more mix that's
another conversation
yeah because it's the same thing you
know like like one time i have a
girlfriend like she don't worry like
nothing you know
i give you like 25 100 each week
oh man she she always said because i
spent 20 bucks
one time because i helped my my friend
to get a membership on the
gym and i paid 20 votes oh she called me
like hey why are you spending 20 bucks
for the camera
you've been giving her how much yeah how
much did you give her like
2500 each week 2500 a week
yeah and she started like screaming for
20 bucks
oh man i said i don't want this this is
a this is a problem i don't want no more
in my life so you you pro
you still with these with these
obstacles with these problems you'd
rather
you'd rather it's always yeah so like
now i just move here
and say i need to start sell it out and
check
what i can do you know i need to find
somebody i can trust
really trust me you know because if you
were to go back to mexico
what would you do uh i can go you can
work yeah i can find any
yeah i the same thing i can do here i
can do over there like
over there i can i i know how to work
like machines you know like cnc
router like like tools you know like
what stops you from doing that like the
pay over there you know
like it's not really good you make her
though yeah i can make more money here
and i want to build my house over there
or
maybe buy things here you know like like
the last year
i i lost my truck i buy that i have
children
like 2011 i paid i pay
cash in one year eleven thousand
in one year you know so now you have no
vehicle yeah and i have to lose it
because that
that is a problem you know like when i
lose money for
another things i have to start selling
my tools because i need to pay the
people you know like my workers
i can live with money my workers you
know and so you've had no problems with
the law anything like that
no nothing like that you're just you're
just trying to make a
a buck yeah
and i always lose like a lot of money
you know like all my machines
everything like they are expensive
machining
like every time every time it's the same
thing you know as
as a man born in mexico is everyone born
in mexico
trying to figure out a way to come to
the u.s no really
my first time i want to come here is for
because my dad you know i want to say
you know help me just
to get a story here or let me like get a
job
you know and he never helped me so i
said well i would do it for myself
you know what was your dad's story why
was he not in your life oh
he just smoked here like he said i don't
have kids and i think he
forget about us you know he make money
for himself
like he get married i have a half
brother
i never meet he never told me i find out
for myself i mean your solution might be
marrying a nice girl here in america
yeah like but you know i trust i don't
want to marry like
somebody used to get a paper because
that's no no no no no no no
you know like people they're not saying
that kind of yeah people they do that
and i don't like that you know if
because people they they get twisted
like yeah don't give me money no oh
i know one that kind of problems i'm not
suggesting anything other than falling
in love and
yeah burying some of your trust because
it's too many problems you know if you
do that and
for me that's enough option you know i'm
never going to get married somebody
just for the papers yeah that is
something wrong for me these people do
that quite often yeah
they do yeah like you know like trying
to find somebody no oh
no no i don't want that kind of problem
in my life
how did you come to the united states
how did you get here uh is it difficult
no i got a visa but it's harder now
right yeah
like that's why i just keep working you
know like trying to do it but like if
you're if your brothers wanted to come
to the u.s they couldn't do it now
i don't think so no i all my family is
over there
i'm only here in this video being put
out there would it get you in trouble
no not at all believe me i know i'm not
afraid
because you know like i say i do it this
because i wanna
be somebody you know and you you need to
find a way
like whatever you have to do you need to
try
you need to fight like always in the
company they know
about my status but and just work work
work you know like
my word is my recommendation so i never
be afraid for that
any problem i get like believe me like
that's fine
if some is they depart me like i know
because i know that rules the laws that
is what it is you know
so it's it's not your fault it's not my
fault like
i'm i'm dealing willing to deal with
everything because
that's just what it is you do use drugs
sometimes
yes what what what drugs will you use i
really use we
i use cocaine i use crystal
and and use them a lot or like
what will i use a little bit no
no more like cocaine i use for one time
like i use
a lot cocaine but i use quit i say you
know i don't want no more
crystal yes i smoke crystal like a
little bit no to
no too much too much that that the the
worst drug is cocaine like
yeah that when i just cocaine like i use
too much
just for work you know like that give me
like energy
energy yeah that's why i say you know
like sometimes depression like because i
have to worry like
on the day and night so the drug use
comes from what trying to
to keep working and deal with the stress
of everything yeah
like that for that you know because i
like i have to start like one job in the
night like 10
and get off like six and i started like
the next
job like nine in the morning if you need
like four
pm oh well crystal meth comes in handy
then yeah so i
because you know sometimes i have to
leave some people working in one job
and they not show up so i finished my
job at night and i have to cover that
that day and it's it's hard i can find
nothing
that's give me like a web in the energy
to do it
that's why i say you know it's not
really good sometimes it's not another
way
you need to juice it but do you think
you're an addict you have
no because i can quitting you you quit
sometimes yeah
like i say i don't want no more no more
and you stop for a long time
but when you when you need it to work
those kind of hours
i need to use it yeah because it's
nothing is going to
keep me awake you know to work like two
turns like
you use it like coffee let's put it that
way like yeah
yeah yeah it's it's it's it's it's funny
you know
it's because i say you know like how if
i used
a lot of cocaine you know like you you
get a tick you know
i said one day i don't know yeah that's
it i don't have a problem
you don't have your ticket no and
and that's not funny for me you know
like i can say that you know it's the
same thing
like more crystal you know like i said i
don't wanna you know i use queen
i don't have symptoms like i hate it
nothing
nothing that's good you know not that i
recommend drug use but no no yeah you
know bro i i
i keep that control in the situation you
know that's great
and i i know it is going to sound like
bad you know but sometimes you have to
use it
to keep a like do something you know
don't let control
drugs control you because if you take
the drugs control you you're going to
lose
so always keep that in mind you know
like don't less
control by drugs that's my
best counsel to everyone you know don't
lose that fight
if you lose the fight you mess around
with everything and how are the people
different in mexico or here in the u.s
when you come
now that you're here how is how is it
culturally different
like here like you have more
opportunities
to grow up you want to fight for
something like
open your business you can do it you
know working hard and get job training
or education yeah
yeah you know like you you need to work
hard you know and you can get the money
little by little you can make it over
there in mexico it's impossible
if you don't have the cash you're never
going to make it
and here you can you can open doors you
know like work
because you work how you work how do you
do
everything that is going to help you to
open like the door
for something for get a contract you
know
you whatever how you do your work is
your recommendation everywhere
you know and that's the way i open the
original i'm still working like
these these in different companies you
send money back to your family
yeah or with my mom i take care of my
mom
my brother's no more my my mom and so
what do you plan for your future
like i want to make my life here
you know but you want to find a nice
secure way to so i can open my company
again
like i'm not going to stop but i need
somebody i can trust like
is that person need to help me like grow
up like
really good yeah what what's what's been
the most important lesson you've learned
[Music]
is it it's hard but you need to trust uh
money is always corrupt people it
corrupts people
yeah so you need you need to keep i need
to keep trying
but that is a big problem you never know
money like when they see a lot of money
like thousands like
gas is changed people's mind
so they can break you like they can give
you
stab you in your body just for the money
i like your i like your perseverance
you know but that is that this card is
yeah
so i need to find somebody like the
money is no no it's going to break down
you know i understood that is the only
solution i find but i need to keep
trusting you know it's not another way i
can do it
no you have a good head on your
shoulders and you're willing to work and
that's that's important
yeah okay rubble thank you so much for
talking with me
and good luck finding somebody who can
handle your money that you can trust
that's important yeah all right well
thank you very much you're welcome thank
you
you